- So, President Trump has
sent a cease and desist letter
to the RNC saying that
they can't use his name
and likeness for fundraising purposes.
Trump has sent many cease and
desist letters in the past,
and often they have resulted
in absolutely nothing whatsoever.
So you might think that
this cease and desist letter
is also meritless,
but there might actually
be something to this.
Just because Trump was president
doesn't mean he can't use his
name and likeness anymore.
Individuals often can
control the monetization
of their likeness.
Now, some jurisdictions say that
if you are a celebrity or a politician,
you can't sue for
misappropriation of likeness,
you're a public figure.
But most jurisdictions
say that even politicians
or celebrities can still monetize
and control the use of their likeness.
It just depends on whether
their likeness is being used
for exploitative purposes or not.
And fundraising emails from the RNC
probably qualify as exploitative
and Trump might be on legal footing
if he wants to prevent them
from using his name and likeness.
So, this likeness is
telling you to subscribe,
or I will see you in court.